- [Instructor] We are
told the polynomial p of x
is equal to four x to the
third plus 19 x squared
plus 19 x minus six has a
known factor of x plus two.
Rewrite p of x as a
product of linear factors.
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at that.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
So if they didn't give
us this second piece
of information that as a known factor of x
plus two, this polynomial
would not be so easy to factor.
But because we know we have a known factor
of x plus two, I could divide that
into our expression and
figure out what I have
left over, and then see if
I can factor from there.
So let's do that.
Let's divide x plus two
into our polynomial.
So it's four x to the third power plus 19
x squared plus 19 x minus six.
And we've done this
multiple times already.
We look at the highest-degree terms.
X goes into four x to the third.
Four x squared times, I
put that in the x squared
or the second-degree column.
Four x squared times x
is four x to the third.
Four x squared times two is
eight x, eight x squared.
And then I wanna subtract
these from what I have up here.
So I'll subtract.
And then I'm going to be
left with 19 x squared
minus eight x squared is 11 x squared.
And then I will bring
down, bring down the 19 x.
So plus 19 x.
And so once again, look
at x and 11 x squared.
X goes into 11, x squared 11 x times.
So that's plus 11 x.
11 x times x is 11 x squared.
11 x times two is 22 x.
Need to subtract these from
what we have in that teal color.
And we are left with 19
minus 22 of something
is negative three of that something.
In this case, it's negative three x.
And then we bring down that negative six.
And then we look at, once again, at the x
and the negative three x.
X goes into negative three
x negative three times.
And so negative three times
x is negative three x.
Negative three times two is negative six.
And then if we wanna
subtract what we have in red
from what we have in magenta.
So I could just multiply
them both by negative.
And so everything just cancels
out and we have no remainder.
And so we can rewrite p of x now.
We can rewrite p of x as being equal to x
plus two times all of this business,
four x squared plus 11 x minus three.
Now we're not done yet because we haven't
expressed it as a product
of linear factors.
This one over here is
linear but four x squared
plus 11 x minus three,
that's still quadratic.
So we have to factor that further.
And let's see, there's a couple of ways
we could approach it.
We could use, well, we could try with this
and the quadratic formula or
we could factor by grouping.
And to factor by grouping,
and the whole reason
we have to factor by grouping is we have
a leading coefficient
here that is not one.
And so we need to think of two numbers
whose product is equal to
four times negative three.
So we have to think of
two numbers, let's just
call them a and b.
A times b needs to be equal to four times
negative three, which is negative 12.
And a plus b needs to be equal to 11.
And so the best that I
can think of, they have
to be opposite signs 'cause their product
is a negative.
So If I had negative, if
I had, if I had positive
12 and negative one, that works.
If a is equal to negative
one and b is equal
to positive 12, that works.
And so what I wanna do is I wanna take
this first-degree term
right over here, 11 x,
and I wanna split it into a
12 x and a negative one x.
So let's do that.
So I can, let's just focus on this part,
on this part right now
and then I'll put it all
back together at the end.
So I can rewrite all of this
business as four x squared.
And instead of writing the 11 x there,
I'm gonna use this blue
color, I'm gonna break
it up as a 12 x.
So plus 12 x and then minus one x.
Notice these two still add up to 11 x.
And then I have my minus three.
And then, let's see,
out of these first two
what can I factor out?
Let's see, I can factor out a four x.
So I can rewrite these first two as,
and if this is unfamiliar
to you I encourage you
to review factoring by
grouping on Khan Academy.
So if we factor out a
four x that's going to be,
it's going to be, we're
gonna be left with an x here.
And then we're gonna be
left with a three over here.
And then these second
two terms, if we factor
out a negative one, so
I'll write negative one,
times, we're going to
have an x plus three.
And so then we can factor
out the x plus three.
So let's do that.
I'm running out of colors.
So I factor out the x
plus three and I am left
with x plus three times, times four x.
And I'm gonna keep these colors the same
so you know where I got 'em from.
Four x minus one.
This is a very colorful
solution that we have over here.
And there you have it.
I factored the second part
into these two factors.
And so now I can put it all together.
I can rewrite p of x as a
product of linear factors.
P of x is equal to x plus
two times x plus three
times four x minus one.
Four x minus one.
And we are done.